c'est un c'est un honneur d'être d'être
présent aujourd'hui devant vous j'avais
préparé un texte je vous le laisserai
d'ailleurs mais je vais m'en évader tout
de suite pour répondre le plus possible
directement au aux sujets qui sont
évoqués par le président et pour cadrer
un peu le
sujet au fond qu'est-ce qu'on appelle
transition énergétique quelle est
l'ambition de la France quels sont les
les les les caractéristiques de la
France dans le monde quels sont les
besoins énergétiques et quel le meilleur
mix énergétique non seulement en terme
de production mais en terme d'approche
d'un manière
générale d'abord je merci Monsieur
Président vous m'avez demandé quelques
quelques éléments sur EDF en soit la
société EDF qui est maintenant une
société côté en bourse donc dont j'ai
l'honneur d'être le responsable c'est
unere reprise société anonyme donc côté
sur le marché de de
Paris au C
40 dont la capitalisation boursière
avant les événements de la semaine
dernière était de l'ordre de 53 54
milliards d'euros un peu fondu pour des
raisons
anecdotiques c'est une entreprise qui
fait à peu près 80 milliards de chiffres
d'affaires je parle un euros bien
entendu dont 2 tiers en France un tiers
à l'international qui vocation
évidemment avoir ce la partie
internationale se renforcer qui compte
de l'ordre de
165000 collaborateurs avant la prise en
compte de l'intégration de DA qui doit
se produire en des premier durant la
première quinzaine du mois de juillet si
Bruxelles selon toute attente donne son
feu vert dalc c'est 15000 personnes et
c'est de leur de 8 milliard de Chi
d'affaires enfin voilà donc on sera un
peu au-dessus de 85 milliards et avec
175000 collaborateurs
euh c'est une entreprise c'est le
premier électricien du monde c'est le
premier
opérateur nucléaire au monde c'est le
premier opérateur hydrolicien en Europe
c'est le premier opérateur de réseau en
Europe et l'un des plus grands au
monde c'est le premier centre de
recherche mondial en matière
d'électricité c'est la référence
mondiale en matière de système
électrique queedf au fond c'est le
premier investisseur européen ce que
beaucoup de gens ignorent nous avons un
plan d'investissement si Dieu le permet
c'est-à-dire si on ne nous désarçonne
pas par des mesures qui nous
interdiraient de faire face à ces
engagement nous avons un plan
d'investissement deord de 200 milliards
d'euros dans les 10 ans qui viennent
dont 120 milliards à peu près en France
et 80 milliards à l'international dont
le programme britannique du nucléaire
particulièrement ns grosses
internationale sont évidemment la
Grande-Bretagne l'Italie l'Europe
centrale y compris la Belgique et la
Pologne nous sommes le premier opérateur
français prier opérateur britannique 2è
opérateur italien 3è opérateur polonais
2è opérateur belge nous sommes depuis 30
ans en Chine ceux qui nous connaissent
le savent nous avons exporté là-bas
notre compétence dans le domaine du
nucléaire nous sommes dans l'hydraulique
au Laos nous sommes en Amérique latine
notamment au Brésil qui fait aujourd'hui
parler de lui nous sommes en Amérique du
Nord nous sommes au Moyen-Orient et nous
avons des ambitions partout voilà ce
qu'est EDF en quelques
mots
l'énergie il il y a des phases de
l'histoire du monde alors d'abord le
monde le monde c'est 7 milliards
d'habitants aujourd'hui c'était 1
milliard et demi au début du 20e siècle
on perd souvent euh je dirais la mémoire
de ce qu'est l'évolution du monde le
monde a quintuplé sa population malgré
les deux grandes guerres mondiales du
20e siècle en l'espace d'un siècle ça
sera 9 milliards d'habitants d'ici
2030 on voit ce que ça implique comme
conséquence en matière de besoins
primaires en eau en énergie en
nourriture en santé besoins
fondamentaux et quand on regarde la
France vu du vaste monde on n' pas le
sentiment qu'on est dans cette univers
la référence dans ces domaines
d'activité extrêmement précis et
extrêmement précieux ne le perdons pas
de vue tout le monde a un regard
particulier vers le système français en
matière d'énergie parce que la France a
su anticiper c'est un des domaines dans
lesquels la France dispose un at tout
absolument unique parce qu'au début des
années 70 en constatant que au fond
les chocs pétroliers allaient se
multiplier la France a pris initiative
de se doter dans le domaine de
l'électricité d'un outil unique au monde
qui est sa plateforme nucléaire qui
avait vocation à donner à la France à la
fois son indépendance dans le domaine de
l'énergie électrique et la compétitivité
du territoire et de
fait quelques 35 ans plus tard on
constate que la France est le seul
exportateur le premier exportateur
d'électricité en Europe et c'est le pays
dont le coût de l'électricité le coût de
R est le plus faible en Europe
donc nous sommes totalement indépendants
dans ce domaine et nous avons une
capacité d'exportation et un atout de
compétitivité article article 2 on
redécouvre ce qui l'énergie
aujourd'hui lors de la campagne
électorale pour le MDEF j'avais eu la
visite des candidats et les uns et les
autres me rappeler que l'énergie
finalement c'était pour l'entreprise
France c'estàd tous les secteurs
d'activité confondu en matière
d'industrie pour l'industrie française
le le le coût du travail représentait 40
% de la moyenne des coûts de la
production industrielle française le
coût de l'énergie 20 %. quand on sait
les difficultés et les drames que
représente le gain d' 1 % sur le coût du
travail on voit l'importance qu'il y a à
ne
pas oublier l'importance de la
compétitivité liée au coût de l'énergie
les Américains sont là pour le prouver
car avec les gaz de c'est la révolution
technologique que représente les gaz de
C aux États-Unis dont le coût du vous le
savez en tout cas historiquement le coût
du gaz aux États-Unis a été divisé par 4
au cours des 10 dernières années et on
voit les évolutions considérables que
cela a impliqué en matière de
réindustrialisation du territoire
nordaméricain de la création d'emplois
l'essentiel du rebond industriel
américain provenant du coût de
l'énergie voilà les les attendus du
sujet enfin notons qu'en France si on
regarde les chiffres 98 % des 70
milliards de déficit du commerce
extérieur français sont tout simplement
liés à l'importation d'énergie fossile
gaz et pétrole c'est-à-dire que si on on
faisait l'économie des importations
d'énergie fossile il n'y aura plus de
déficit du commerce extérieur français
et ce déficit se creuse d'année en année
voilà les enjeux compétitivité pouvoir
d'achat industrialisation emploi
investissement
alors parlons de transition
énergétique le sujet de la France qu'
est-il 1 comment économiser l'énergie de
manière à importer moins et à subir
moins de déficit dece exérieur tout en
gardant la compétitivité du territoire
article et article 2 qu le mix
énergétique susceptible de répondre le
mieux à cette
attente
donc dans les attendu d'une réflexion
STR sur l'optimisation énergétique sur
ce qu'on peut appeler la transition
énergétique je voudrais qu'on
oublie simplement le terme transition
électrique le pourcentage
d'électronucléaire dans les productions
d'électricité regardons la transition
énergétique
avec comme priorité la première des
priorités c'est les économies d'énergie
comment faire en sorte que le pays
économise l'énergie qu' consomme qu'il
consomme de manière efficiente efficace
quelles sont les mesures à prendre en
matière d'économie d' qui à la fois
relève du bon sens qui relève de
l'efficacité économique et pas
uniquement de la subvention comment
faire en sorte que le pays s'engage dans
la voie d'une optimisation énergétique
au sens des économies d'énergie efficac
ça c'est la première des priorités la
deuxième c'est quels sont les besoins en
énergie du pays à l'horizon des années
2030-240 bon en se projetant de cet
univers là en tenant compte de
l'évolution de la France dans la période
intermédiaire entre 2012 date à laquelle
on a lancé ce modordre de transition
énergétique et les années 2030 2040 et
troisièmement quel est le meilleur mix à
ce moment-là adapté pour
permettre l'efficacité des mesures qui
sont adaptées qui sont
entreprises il faut faire des hypothèses
dans C donc la France de 2025 2030 2035
ne ressemblera pas sera pas tout à fait
la même elle sera pas figée dans la
Marme ça sera pas la France de 2012
d'abord parce que la France a une des
caractéristiques uniques en son genre en
Europe c'est un pays dont la démographie
est positive seul pays européen dont la
démographie est significativement
positive l'ORD de 2 % par an ce qui est
exactement l'inverse de l'Allemagne ou
de l'Italie et quand on fait des
comparaisons on oublie toujours ça
l'Allemagne se des peuples l'Italie se
des peuples la France ce peuple 2 % par
an ça veut dire que d'ici
2025 par exemple il y aura 6 millions
d'habitants de plus en France les
besoins de la France ne seront pas les
mêmes qu'en 2012 bon
deuxièmement la croissance économique
car aujourd'hui en France vous avez 70 %
de la consommation d'électricité et je
pense d'énergie au sens large il faudra
le vérifier qui sont
liés au
particulier
et 30 % enfin 2 tiers en tiers à peu
près lié à l'entreprise à l'économie à
l'industrie évidemment les besoins de
l'industrie sont directement corrélés à
la croissance du secteur industriel et
donc si on ve regarder les besoins de la
France en les anticipant et les
compagant il faut avoir une idée de ce
que va être le développement et la
croissance économique de ce pays dans
les 20 à 30 ans qui viennent il m'est
arrivé d'imaginer je dirais pas de rêver
mais d'imaginer que la France comme
d'autres d'ailleurs pourrait avoir un
taux de croissance de l'ordre de 2 à 2
demi % par an à effet composer ce qui
est nécessaire pour maintenir l'emploi
dans ce pays d'autant que la croissance
démographique est là pour renforcer ce
besoin et bien si on se projette à cet
horizon-l alors vous voyez que les
besoins en énergie de la France compte
tenu
des économies d'énergie dont on peut
imaginer qu'elle représente 20 %
d'économie sur l'ensemble des énergies à
l'horizon de 2 2025 2030 que malgré tout
les besoins d'énergie du pays compte
tenu de la croissance démographique et
de la croissance économique resteront
positif ça c'est le besoins en énergie
ensuite quels sont les énergies les plus
efficaces je constate que dans en France
nous importons toutes nos énergies
primaires à l'exception de
l'électricité toutes les les énergies
fossiles sont importées donc on a aucun
avantage compétitif dans ces domaines là
tout est importé nous n'avons pas de
ressources
propre seule l'électricité n'est pas
importée mais est fabriquée et même nous
donne un petit bonus à l'exportation
donc si je devais donner une priorité au
mix énergétique français je pense qu'on
aurait tout intérêt à pousser la
consommation d'une énergie qui est la
plus compétitive parce qu'elle se
détache clairement par rapport à la
moyenne européenne en électricité on est
40 % moins cher que la moyenne
européenne plutôt que dans les énergies
fossiles dont on peut dire que ça nous
donne aucun avantage compétitif puisque
nous les importons en totalité ce qui
n'est pas le cas par exemple de la
Norvège bien sûr ou de la
Grande-Bretagne jusqu'à une date
prochaine puisque les ressources sont en
train de s'épuiser et puis par ailleurs
elles sont en Écosse qui fait l'objet
d'un référendum que vous l'avez
peut-être
mentionné
donc si d'aventure on me posait la la
question citoyen que je suis donc pas au
président de DF de savoir quelle énergie
il faut favoriser en France je dirais
bon d'abord il faut regarder les besoins
en énergie au sens large et à
l'intérieur des énergies l'énergie la
plus propre celle qui est la plus
efficace celle qui est la plus
compétitive celle qui est la
plus comment dirais-je qui donne le le
le l'indépendance énergétique puisqu'on
la produit nous-même c'est l'électricité
si j'ajoute à
ça que l'évolution
naturelle des besoins des particuliers
et des entreprises c'est-à-dire dire
toutes les nouvelles technologies
nouvelles applications la modernité
l'efficacité tous les éléments concours
à faire en sorte que dans le
portefeuille dans le portefeuille
énergétique de chacun d'entre nous la
part de l'électricité augmente en valeur
relative d'année en année
plus le temps passe plus l'électricité
domine le paysage de du mix énergétique
individuel des foyers français par
définition puisque toutes les nouvelles
applications encore une fois et
aujourd'hui encore plus à travers la
mobilité l'électricité domine le paysage
donc et pour faire simple dans nos
calculs dans les calculs que la nation
devrait faire il y a d'abord en priorité
les économies d'énergie ensuite
l'optimisation du mix énergétique et
enfin à l'intérieur du système
électrique queles sont les origines de
l'électricité qui sont les plus
efficaces ma conviction celle qui
ressort de nos calculs et nous sommes là
pour vous donner toutes les tous les
éléments d'information sont que les
projections en ma matière de besoins en
énergie et de la part de l'électricité
dans l'énergie font que à l'horizon 2028
2030 les besoins en électricité de la
France sans qu'il y ait un changement
considérable dans la répartition des des
énergies mais accompagnant l'évolution
vers l'électricité du mix énergétique
global les besoins en électricité de la
France seront tels que le parc nucléaire
existant y compris le nou le nouveau
réacteur de flamandville suffiront à
peine
50 % des besoins d'électricité de la
France si les 2% de entre de et% de
croissance é récomposé son
son sont au rendez-vous et si on prend
en compte l'évolution démographique et
malgré les 20 % d'économie d'énergie
voilà le créd sur lequel évidemment je
ne demande à personne de nous rejoindre
les yeux fermés mais en tout cas qui
justifie qu'on se pose au moins la
question oui parc existant par donc
c'està-dire la capacité de production
aujourd'hui
qui 58 réacteurs français existants plus
nveau
réacteur
deuxièmement le coût des énergies quel
est le coût de production de
l'électricité provenant des origines
diverses
aujourd'hui on peut dire que le si on on
met de côté aujourd'hui la France
dispose de 75 % de DEES de sa production
électrique à partir de
l'électronucléaire 12 % à peu près 12
et5 % à partir de l'hydraulique et le
reste sous forme soit d'énergie nouvelle
soit
de de fou ou de gaz c'est dire du
thermique classique en pointe
particulièrement
le coût de production du mgaw
électrique pour l'hydraulique c'est
difficile parce qu'il faudrait tenir
compte de l'investissement nécessaire
pour les pour un barrage virtuel les
barrages étant très anciens ils sont
déjà complètement amortis donc le plus
compétitif évidemment l'hydroélectricité
j'y reviendrai dans un instant puisque
président m'a demandé d'y revenir sur le
sujet de la mise en concurrence des
barrages car les barrages sont les seuls
éléments stables fiables et compétitif
de stockage de l'énergie aujourd'hui
avec les ballons de
chaud puisque le stockage de l'énergie
est un sujet sur laquel on travaille
énormément on recherche beaucoup on n'
pas encore trouvé mais
l'eau c'est le meilleur stockage
existant de l'énergie donc les barrages
de
euh l'énergie thermique
d'origine pétrole charbon ou gaz à un
coout qui est compris entre 75
et 80 85 € le
mgaw l'énergie électronucclléaire
provenant du parc nucléaire existant et
la Cour des comptes l'a validé à deux
reprises par les deux analyses qui ont
été faites c'est 55 € le
MWh les énergies
nouvelles l'éolien en fonction alors
sans tenir compte du cout de
l'intermittence qui devrait se rajouter
au coup des énergies nouvelles l'éolien
onshore de l'ordre de 90 à 110 le mgaw
l' lien offshore de l'ordre de 150 à
200 le photovoltaïque de l'ordre de 180
250 voilà les prix te revient bon pour
les énergies nouvelles ne tenant pas
compte encore une fois de
l'intermittence c'est-à-dire des coûts
de structure liés au réseau d'une part
et lié à l'adossement nécessaire à des
moyens classique thermique pour faire
face voilà les coûts maintenant dans le
mix énergétique de
demain
euh forcé de constater que le le coût
moyen des énergies produites à certain
rapport avec le coût de revient final de
l'énergie distribuée que par conséquent
ou bien on les subventionne et dans ce
cas-là ça sort de la pche du
contribuable plutôt que du du du du
consommateur ou bien fait payer le coup
énergie effectivement au consommateur
mais de toute manière rien n rien ne se
per rien de secré et il faut que cette
énergie soit
rémunérée à partir de
là l'hydraulique est effectivement un
élément extrêmement précieux le parc
nucléaire existant est un atout
compétitif absolument majeur le nouveau
nucléaire coûtera plus cher que le parc
existant et il faudra faire en sorte
d'améliorer son coup pour qu'il
deviennne compétitif on peut imaginer
qu'on soit capable à terme de produire
de l'électronucléaire autour du prix du
thermique c'est-à-dire autour de 75 € le
MWh on est capable de le faire mais je
ne le dis pas officiellement euh et puis
euh et puis les énergies nouvelles on
gagnera un peu en compétitivité mais de
façon marginale par rapport à ce que
j'aiévoqué
euh plus le coûte de l'intermittence qui
représente quoi 30 % du cû des énergies
à peu près rajouter au coût direct
c'est-à-dire que en coût complet on
devrait prendre 30 % de plus pour le
coût des des énergies dites nouvelles
par rapport aux énergies centralisées et
puis s ajoute les énergies réparties
c'est-à-dire toutes les ressources
locales géothermie biomasse
euh les
énergies locales qui peuvent être le
waste energy par exemple la
transformation des déchets en énergie au
travers de l'incinération et toutes les
énergies qui est notamment mais qui
dépendent à la fois de la sociologie de
la démographie de la topographie et
cetera et qui sont à regarder à la
maille régionale ou locale plus qu'All
maille
nationale voilà le le sujet alors à
partir de là si on considère que
l'ambition c'est d'abord de donner un un
à l'électricité la place qui lu permet
de maintenir la compétitivité du
territoire et si on considère que dans
l'électrique dans l'électricité dans la
production électrique le nucléaire doit
être à l'intérieur d'un mix où il soit
moins dominant qu'aujourd'hui avec par
exemple un objectif à 50 % alors on peut
décliner et et dire que 50 % de
d'électron nucléaair et 10 %
d'hydraulique ce qui est à peu près
cohérent avec les hypothèses que j'ai
retenu tout à l'heure de croissance
économique et de croissance
démographique puisque les 12 et demi
vont nevenir 10 dans les mêmes
hypothèses et bien ça laisse 40 %
d'énergie à à à produire qui sont qui
sont aujourd'hui
n qu'il est nécessaire d'envisager
là-dessus les égies nouvelles ont toutes
leur place encore une fois dans le souci
de maintenir la compétitivité du
territoire et la compétitivité
économique voilà ce qu'on peut dire en
quelques mots vous m'avez monsieur le
Président posé la question sur
l'hydraulique
euh pour préciser ma pensée monsieur le
Président je pense tout simplement à la
compagnie nationale du Ron et pourquoi
ne pas trop une solution du même type en
particulier avec les collectivités dans
le cadre de la loi que nous avons voté à
l'unanimité la loi
SOP c'està-dire une SEM à Opération
unique concernant un appel d'offre qui
pourrait
être ouvert par rapport au
renouvellement des concessions c'est
exactement ça que j'avais en tête
lorsque je vous ai évoqué cette cette
possibilité alors l'hydraulique comme
vous le savez
euh en France l'hydraulique est ce sont
des concessions de l'État eu EDF étant
EDF et ses concurrents étant opérateurs
pour le compte de la nation de l'État
euh des euh des barrages euh qu'il soit
d'ailleurs
euh les barrages de montagne ou ou ou ou
ou les barrages sur sur leurô euh les
concessions arrivent peu à peu à donc la
question est quit de du renouvellement
de ses concessions ou de la mise en
appel d'œure de ses
concessions sa tous que que Bruxelles
souhaite que la concurrence exerce et
que
les ces barrages soient mis en appel
d'offre ce sujet est un sujet largement
débattu connu aujourd'hui je disais tout
à l'heure que le coût pour le
pays o ce que le poids
économique de l'hydraulique en France ne
se ne limite pas à la production
d'énergie électrique produite par ces
barrages puisque l'essentiel de du poids
économique est lié à l'optimisation du
système électrique que ces barrages
permettent de réaliser au travers du
stockage c'estàdire au fond ces barrages
servent beaucoup plus à stocker
l'énergie de manière à assumer avec
efficacité les arrêts des grandes
central et la maintenance des des des
des grands sites de production
que par la production elle-même de la
même manière qu'elle permett d'éponger
les pointes c'est donc une utilisation
beaucoup plus rationnelle que la simple
fabrication d'énergie
d'électricité courante par les
barrages dans ce
contexte bien que ne craignant pas la
concurrence DF est tout à fait capable
de remporter les appels d'offre je je
pense que l'optimisation du système
électrique permis par les barrages
est un élément majeur de l'excellence du
système électrique français par
conséquent nous nous sommes nous
déterminé solliciter l'attention de nos
interlocuteurs pour
que associé
à un programme important
d'investissement les concessions
certaines des grandes concessions
puissent être prolongées en contrepartie
des travaux de d'investiss des
investissements nécessaires qu'il est
qu'il est important d'y réaliser et que
nous
puissions au
fond bénéficier d'une extension de la de
la durée des concession au moins pour
une partie importante des barrages de
manière à maintenir l'efficacité du
système électrique français ce débat est
en cours alternatives sont possibles
appel d'OF tout court ou toute autre
forme de partenariat public privés qui
ont été évoqués et qui sont toujours
possibles euh la
dimension régionale et locale est
importante la dimension nationale est
aussi du fait comme je le disais de de
l'outil d'efficacité du système que
représente les les
barrages mesdames et messieurs quelques
grandes réponses à mais
mais étant votre disposition pour les
questions des réponses plus précises aux
questions qui vous souhaitez je vais
passer la parole pour quelques petites
questions et non pas des longues
réponses Monsieur L
nooir monsieur le Président avant
d'aborder la question qui nous réunit je
voudrais vous demander que la Commission
puisse tenir une réunion sur
Alstom des décisions importantes ont été
prises je crois que la Commission des
affffaires économique ne peut pas se
tenir à l'écart des informations qui
sont diffusées ici et là et donc je vous
suggère au nom du groupe UMP que nous
puissions avoir sans tarder une réunion
euh et au préalable avec le ministre en
charge de ce dossier c'est-à-dire euh
Monsieur Arnaud
mondebourg monsieur Lenoir je vais vous
répondre tout de suite à cette question
je suis très favorable d'autant plus que
j'ai eu un contact euh bien en amont
avec général ellectrique France et que
je connaissais un peu les donnes de ce
dossier vous savez très bien que nous
avons auditionné monsieur le ministre
Mbour et que j'avais déjà essayé d'avoir
une réponse mais je comprenais très bien
que il y a un silence radio concernant
les négociations en cours la même chose
d'ailleurs m'a été répondue lors de
l'audition de général électrique France
vous comprendz bien que les personnes
n'allaient pas dévoiler de part et
d'autre leurs atouts en tous les cas si
vous voulez mon sentiment je considère
que c'est la meilleure des solutions
parmi les deux solutions envisag
je le dis posément après avoir écouté
pas après avoir regardé sur l'ensemble
la complémentarité les centre de
décision concernant l'indépendance aussi
énergétique et cetera je crois que moi
je vous donne mon avis personnel et qui
n'engage que moi que c'est la meilleure
des solutions qui a été trouvé
concernant votre proposition monsieur
Lenoir j'y adhère fortement maintenant
faudra trouver un créneau avec Monsieur
Montebourg
euh avant la fin de la
session ça va pas être gagné mais je je
regarde madame de la Bretèche vous avez
une mission de contacter Monsieur
Montebourg j'imaginais bien que cette
question allait nous arriver nous avons
un calendrier législatif relativement
léger monsieur le noir pour ce qui nous
concerne notre commission je parle pas
de la commission Développement Durable
qui n'a rien à faire mais nous nous
avons
un un programme àéger par rapport au
régime que nous avons connu depuis le
début de l'année ça nous fait d'ailleurs
tout drôle et donc j'adhère complètement
à votre idée d'auditionner d'or et avant
ou le ministre ou général
électrique comme vous le souhaitez
monsieur Loir monsieur le Président très
clairement d'abord monsieur
Montebourg pour répondre à votre
observation je trouve que l'architecture
est bonne je l'ai toujours préconisé en
revanche je m'inquiète du contenu
de ce qui a été décidé car il y a de
fortes incertitudes par rapport à la
prise de contrôle par l'État sur le prix
qui sera finalement conclu donc vous
parlez des relations entre
bétat c'est un un autre débat on y
reviendra non mais ça fait partie des
questionsou oui monsieur le noir pas
maintenant monsieur monsieur le
Président je vais revenir maintenant au
sujet qui nous qui nous réunit merci
monsieur le Président de DF d'avoir
apporté des précisions vous l'avez
compris nous avons déjà entamé mais même
si le texte n'est pas encore
connu sur la loi de transition
énergétique quand je dis le texte n'est
pas connu le projet de loi sera porté
par le Conseil des ministres dans dans
quelques dans quelques jours dans
quelques semaines et nous avons eu déjà
des débats à l'intérieur du Sénat au
commission d'abord l'initiative du
président de la commission mais
également en Science Publique avec
Madame Segolen royale donc un certain
nombre de chiffres ont été avancé un
certain nombre d'observations ont été
faites alors je reprends les les
quelques points que vous avez développé
pour insister sur les réponses que vous
nous avez apporté que vous pourrez
préciser il y a un point important c'est
de savoir quelle est la quantité
d'électricité dont nous aurons besoin
d'ici à 2030 2040 c'est un grand débat
quand je dis c'est un grand
débat je lis un certain nombre de
documents qui sont fournis par des gens
qui réfléchissent et je crois que vous
n'êtes pas en contradiction avec les
écrits auxquels j'aimis faire la demande
en électricité va augmenter nous avons
aujourd'hui un gouvernement qui par sa
représentante en charge de l'écologie et
l'énergie nous dit non vous vous trompez
la demande va baisser car nous allons
tout faire pour que on consomme moins
d'électricité c'est un point majeur qu'à
partir de là ce sont les moyens de
production dont nous avons besoin qui
doivent être identifiés et j'ai bien
perçu ce que vous avez dit à savoir
contenu de évolution démographique qui
est un facteur important et souvent
méconnu mais compte tenu aussi de la
croissance espérée nous avons besoin de
maintenir tous les réacteurs nucléaires
actuellement existants en
fonction sans compter les besoins que
nous pouvons avoir par ailleurs alors
j'ai bien noté vous avez dit après
s'agissant du mix mais après tout 50 %
de nucléaire 10 % d'hydraulique 40 %
donc on pourra le problème mais je
comprends que vous ne puissiez pas
l'exprimer ainsi Monsieur le Président
c'est que le renouvelable a besoin de
s'appuyer sur du thermique classique du
thermique à flamme pour compenser
aujourd'hui en Allemagne on a fortement
développer l'éolien photovoltaïque mais
pour compenser lorsqu'il y a pas de vent
lorsqu'il y a pas de soleil qu'est-ce
qu'on fait on met en route des centrales
charbon la part du charbon est en train
d'augmenter or nous sommes en charge
dans le casadre de la transition
énergétique pas seulement euh de la du
besoin en énergie mais
également de la protection du climat
donc ce point doit être
important deuxièmement moi je le dis
parce que nous sommes ici dans une
assemblée où on peut exprimer son
opinion pour un certain nombre de
personnes le débat sur la transition
énergétique c'est tout simplement la
mort du nucléaire c'est l'arrê du
nucléaire alors je sais que au
gouvernement on n est pas là
on ne le dit pas et même je je le dis
comme je le pense la communication qu'a
fait madame CEN royale a dû certainement
surprendre voir
dvoir des éléments écologistes qui
appartiennent à notre assemblée et donc
effectivement on n pas vu d'échéan
annoncées
concernant la fermeture de centrale
nucléaire on est loin des engagements
qui ont été pris de fermer 24 réacteur
d'ici à 2025 et on ne parle pas de F
c'est un point important car nous allons
certainementir avoir besoin de cette
électricité alors maintenant le coût
monsieur le Président vous le savez il y
a eu une commission d'enquête ici au
Sénat il y en a une à l'Assemblée
nationale plus récente sur le coût du
nucléaire bon une chose est sûre c'est
que quels que soit les chiffres
divergent auquel nous nous référons les
uns les autres l'électricité en France
est de loin la moins chère mis à part
les pays du Nord comme vous l'avez
souligné et c'est un point important bon
écoutez on dit moin 40 % par rapport à
nos voisins c'est c'est la moitié par
rapport aux Allemands pour les les
usagers autant autant autant le autant
le rappeler alors sur l'hydraulique une
petite remarque je la fais régulièrement
pour réveiller un peu la mémoire pour
éviter de tenir des propos imprudents la
compagnie nationale du Rône était cogéré
par les collectivités EDF je me permets
de rappeler une loi
de décembre
2001 je me rappelle qui gouvernait la
France à l'époque c'est la loi Murcef
qui a fait que le capital a été ouvert
et que c'est un concurrent de DF en
l'occurrence suè devenu plus tard GDF
suè qui a repris la compagnie nationale
du rô dernier point monsieur le
Président qui est important c'est le
prix on a parlé du coût savoir quel est
le prix qu'on paye alors je rappelle
tout le monde le sait mais il y a les
tarifs et il y a les prix du marché bon
les prix du marché on en parle pas c'est
le marché qui les fixe les tarifs c'est
le gouvernement sur avis de la
Commission de régulation de l'énergie
alors il y a un débat qu'on peut pas
occulter ici madame SGEN royale a
annoncé que l'augmentation prévue serait
différée et que de toute façon elle ne
ferait pas du montant qui avait été
annoncé
alors je le dit tout de suite pour
éviter toute mauvaise interprétation que
j'
et
tout
mer vous êtes filial qui font ça quelles
sont leurs considérations dans le cadre
de ce grand ensemble en point enfin un
autre point j'étais rapporteur du paquet
énergie 3 x 20 euh en dehors de ce qu'a
dit jeancode que je partage euh moi je
je mets l'accent sur un vin d'efficacité
énergétique à la taille où vous êtes
avec les contacts que vous avez sur
l'ensemble des consommateurs
d'électricité en France quelle offre de
service avez-vous en réserve et
qu'allez-vous faire demain pour que
l'efficacité énergétique soit vraiment
au niveau où nous
souhaitons si Monsieur Bourquin
oui quelques questions euh je vous
remercie monsieur le Président Directeur
Général pour
votre exposé qui qui situe bien les
enjeux
euh cependant je vrais vous poser une ou
deux
questions la première quand on parle de
transition on parle de dépendance à une
seule source d'énergie et on aborde la
possibilité d'avoir plusieurs sources
d'énergie et de diversifier ses ces
sources d'énergie et il ne serait
calamiteux d'avoir le débat sur la
transition pour ou contre le nucléaire
serait vraiment
dommageable la question c'est aborder
toutes les questions tes que vous l'avez
fait dans votre exposé
l'approvisionnement en énergie qui est
fondamental pour une
société on parle de compétitivité on
parle
d'indépendance sont des questions
vitales aujourd'hui avec l'indépendance
alimentaire après il y a les questions
de politique d'économie
d'énergie ça s'est posé avec une force
inédite et
ensuite l'avance que nous avons et que
vous avez bien fait remarquer comme
grand groupe concernant la maîtrise du
nucléaire et la production
d'électricité comment vous la mettez à
profit pour justement prendre de
l'avance et ne pas laisser cette avance
simplement aux Allemands concernant les
énergie alternative non stockable dont
vous parliez et dont le problème est le
le stockage justement je pense le vent
l'eau et bien d'autres sources d'énergie
là on
a on sait très bien mais je crois que
vous êtes mieux placé que nous pour le
savoir que l'innovation dans la
production énergétique va prendre une
dimension tout à fait inédit
exceptionnelle j'ai rencontraé une
start-up il y a de cela quelques mois
qui me disait que il allaient produire
du carburant avec des algues h et que ce
carburant pouvait être
infini et et surtout non producteur de
CO2 alors bien sûr il ventait il ventait
ses sa start-up et son produit mais on
sait qui si est là en Israël dans
beaucoup d'endroits il y a des
chercheurs qui mettent au
point des systèmes
comment
EDF avec la puissance de feu qui est là
excusez-moi c'est peut-être pas la bonne
métaphore mais avec la puissance qu'elle
a prépare l'avenir pour que on sait très
bien que il y a eu et il y a aujourd'hui
une suprématie du nucléaire qui sera qui
sera un jour remplacé par une autre
suprématie concernant la production
d'électricité voilà je finis monsieur le
le directeur sur un sujet qui me tient à
cœur
vous avez parlé d'un sujet concernant
l'hydrolisme et les barrages j'en ai un
dans ma
région
et il a un gros problème c'est qu'il est
régulièrement le chatel dans le dou vers
la
franco-suisse il est régulièrement en
travaux et quand il est en travaux et
bien c'est un carnage
pisicol et comment fait-on pour pour
éviter comme vous le disiez tout à
l'heure
quand
l'hydroollyisme vient prendre le relais
de nucléaire comment on fait pour éviter
les lâchés de fond qui sont
catastrophiques pour les rivières et
comment on fait par exemple l'adreal par
exemple de franchecé a a proposé de
créer un bipass au niveau de la centrale
afin d'éviter que la rive gauche par
exemple qui qui est régulièrement en
travaux ne soit exondé en cas de rupture
ça ce sont des une question que je vous
pose à côté mais qui n'est pas une
petite question parce que si à chaque
barrage et si on
revient sur et j'ai bien écouté monsieur
Proglio il a raison de dire que
l'hydraulisme doit être développé
l'hydraulique oui l'hydraulique doit
être développé et que dans l'hydraulique
il y a les concessions et si elle vient
systématiquement pour combler les les
questions de de de de de comment de
Perre d'électricité de puissance
d'électricité faisons en sorte que ça se
fasse en respectant
l'environnement merci euh monsieur
sido bien merci monsieur le Président
moi j'ai bien écouté le l'exposé de
Monsieur Proglio président desdf et je
le remercie c'est très clair
euh il s'ag il s'agirait que le débat
soit et les données soient très claires
au moment où on on discutera de la loi
sur la transition euh énergétique et en
particulier tout tourne au-delà des
volontés politiques louables et cetera
tout tourne autour du prix ou des coûts
il y en a qui font la différence entre
les deux bon très bien des subtilités
qui m'échappe enfin bref des prix et et
vous avez donné les prix monsieur le
Président et je vous en remercie
l'hydroélectrique c'est le plus bas en
fain tout est amorti un jour il faudra
refaire les barrages en tenons compte du
prix du kilo de poisson effectivement
euh le thermique vous l'avez dit c'est
le valeur aujourd'hui demain on ne sait
pas euh les énergies nouvelles vous avez
bien dit effectivement où on en était
sans compter l'intermittence
c'est-à-dire qu'il faut une puissance
équivalente installé au pied du
madeléolienne que ce qui est installé en
haut euh je trouve que 30 30 % de plus
vous êtes très modeste vous n'avez pas
forcé le trait et je vous en remercie ça
permet d'éclairer le débat
ceci étant dit je et je termine par le
nucléaire je me souviens qu'on a discuté
d'une loi il y a pas si longtemps vous
vous battiez pour qu'on vende que vous
vendiez le megaw 42 € hein c'est bien ça
vous souvz bon on en est à
55 et moi je vous pose la question
monsieur non mais je je discute pas moi
je suis pas spécialiste de la question
je suis pas comme
d'cun mais je vous pose la questions
d'où vient euh cette dérive c'est là où
je vou en venir
non non attendez attendez je m'explique
attendez monsieur le Président je
m'explique euh d'où vient cette dérive
du prix du kilwh et où est-ce que ça va
s'arrêter parce Queau fond toute la
question est là
euh on ne sait pas au fond combien
véritablement quel est le prix du mégawh
ou du kilwh comme vous voudrez du
nucléaire parce que tout simplement
pourquoi parce que déjà les normes de
démantelllement des futur
démantelllement des centrales on en
rajoute tous les jours alors
forcément ça
se attaché au prix du kilwhur demain
puisqu'on en rajoute tous les jours les
bétons qui n'ont absolument aucun bécrel
à distribuer B il faut faudra les mettre
à morvier dans l'Aube et donc faire
traverser la France à des millions de
tonnes de de déchets pour aucune raison
justifiable précise il faudrait
peut-être aborder le débat
d'ailleurs et puis je voudrais aborder
quelque chose qui me très à cœur c'est
le coût naturellement du projet
CGO tant que on ne connaît pas le coût
du projet CGO en toute bonne foi
monsieur le
Président vous êtes bien
incapable je le comprends bien
d'ailleurs d'afficher un prix du du
kilwh
et plus les années passent plus le
projet CGO augmente en cout et ça ne
provient pas des augmentations des
subventions au territoire non non
ça ça provient ça provient bien de je ne
sais pas je sais pas quoi d'ailleurs
exactement et où est-ce que ça va
s'arrêter puis en plus demain on nous
demande encore un moratoire de 2 ans
pour réfléchir et cetera et cetera bien
entendu l'endra je veux pas reprendre le
mot du général de Gaulle mais landendra
est forcément ravi de chercher 2 ans de
plus enfin le coû de
l'endra sans rien faire c'est 200
millions d'euros c'est combien ça coûte
combien l'endra par an par an rien que
de faire tourner quand est-ce que ça va
s'arrêter monsieur le Président à votre
avis alors que on a plus les moyens en
France de payer toutes ces dérives et
par conséquent j'aimerais bien avoir
votre
sentiment sur cette bah on navance pas
au niveau de l'endra de la loi qui
aurait dû être attaché dans un titre
supplémentaire sur la transition
énergétique ça y est on apprend j'ai
appris ça hier AB
d'ailleurs que finalement ça serait plus
dans la transitionique mais dans une
autre loi
demain pour et cetera alors ce que je
voulais vous dire Monsieur le Président
pour terminer c'est que en tant que
président de l'Office Parlementaire je
vais organiser au mois de septembre une
audition qui me semble
importante importante parce que sans que
je ne demande rien du tout plusieurs
intervenants de des opérateurs
d'électricité en Allemagne ont demandé à
me voir je les ai donc reçu puisque je
reçois tout le monde et ils m'ont dit
écoutez vous la France vous déjà
l'Office Parlementaire c'est très
important nous on n pas l'équivalent en
Allemagne et ça nous semble très
intéressant beaucoup d'acteurs beaucoup
de membres de cet office
éminent ont des idées sur la question et
vous avez commis plusieurs rapports
importants et remarqués sur cette
question et donc on vient vous voir pour
que nous les Allemands on vous aime bien
les Français et oui oui enfin nous les
Allemands producteurs d'électricité hein
j'entends hein on vous aime bien et on
voudrait pas que vous fassiez les mêmes
erreurs que les
nôtres ils n'ont pas dit que nous ce
sont pas les producteur d'électricité
Allemands qui ont commis des erreurs
c'est Angela Merkel qui en 8 jours a
changé d'avis et qui a pris peur après
Fukushima et qui a décidé et cetera bon
et donc je vais avoir une audition de
des producteurs un certain nombre de
producteurs d'électricité allemand mais
naturellement nous sommes à l'office
audition complètement ouverte et
contradictoire naturellement donc vous
serez invité monsieur progliot euh de
même que d'autres en France et puis
monsieur beupin naturellement sera
invité bien entendu euh et tous ceux
tous les contenteurs et tous ceux qui
sont contre et cetera enfin bref pour
qu'on a un vrai débat et que l'Office
Parlementaire puisse en amont de la
discussion sur la transition énergétique
produire un rapport sur ce qui s'est dit
euh dans la journée dans une table ronde
qui sera publique bien entendu avec
journalistes camér et ce et ce voilà ce
que je voulais vous dire mais le le cœur
du sujet c'est le prix du kilwh me
semble-il merci je sais pas que Monsieur
é producteur d'électricité mais bon
monsieur
thier juste une remarque je suis pas SR
que le prix soit le seul facteur de
décision enfin brunud regarder les
choses
monsieurierentin oui monsieur le
Président Directeur Général je n'ai
qu'une question sur un sujet qui devrait
être aussi traité dans la loi sur la
transition que que sont les mesures qui
pourraient être prises pour favoriser la
la pérenité sur le sol français de
grandes entreprises qui sont aussi des
clients de de DF que sont les
électrointensives bon il se trouve qu'il
y a un an vous êtes rentré au capital
d'une société avec un partenaire
allemand pour maintenir sur le sol
national deux entités une dans les PIR é
une dans les Alpes permettant moi je
dois le dire de trouver une solution qui
a maintenu 600 emplois directs 2000
sous-traitants et qui 11 mois après
embauche de nouveau sur les deux sites
que ce soit dans les Pyrenées dans les
Alpes bon cet accord n'est pas allé de
soi au début c'est était difficile mais
je voudrais savoir avec le recul
monsieur le Président Directeur Général
ce que vous retirez de cette expérience
et si nous pouvons
imaginer que EDF puisse
renouveler ce type accord qui a été
validé d'ailleurs par les autorités
bruxelloises sinon nous aurions dû
effectivement y renoncer car je crois
qu'il s'agit là aussi de effectivement
la solidité de l'économie française mais
aussi la balance de l'exportation vous y
êtes attaché comme grand industriel
comme fervant défenseur de de de
l'équipe France et donc je voudrais
savoir si effectivement vous êtes de
nouveau ouvert à ce type de solution
oui oui mais je complèai bien la
question de thréopentin je suis pas sûr
que il y ait pas une évolution de la
part de la Commission de Bruxelles sur
cet accord
enfin j'ai cru comprendre que ils
avaient donné oui le feu vert mais je
suis pas sûr qu'il le renouvelle
monsieur
biset merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président
progliot vous avez parlé tout à l'heure
en début de propos des différents coûts
de l'énergie et je vous en remercie et
vous avez souligné euh l'irruption dans
le paysage énergétique mondial de nos
amis américains qui avec le gaz de
schiste ont totalement modifieré le le
coût de l'énergie et si hier nous avons
malheureusement pu constater des
délocalisation dû au coût horaire du
travail des localisations de l'Europe
vers l'Asie je crains que nous ayons
demain même très rapidement des
délocalisations que j'appellerai
énergéti mais non pas de l'Europe vers
l'Asie mais de l'Europe vers les
États-Unis à cause précisément du coût
de l'énergie je vous donne simplement un
chiffre depuis les ces deux dernières
années un certain nombre de de comment
dirais d'entreprises électrointensivees
Alemande ont investi près de 12
milliards d'euros à l'étranger dont 10
milliards précisément soutendu par le
fait de la recherche d'une énergie moins
moins cher qu'en Allemagne
donc
euh moi ma question la question que je
voulais vous poser concerne l'Europe de
l'énergie je crois que nous sommes
aujourd'hui dans un contexte où on parle
beaucoup de transition énergétique on
s'aperçoit en regardant ce que fait
l'Allemagne que c'est surtout pas
l'exemple qu'il faut qu'il faut suivre
et que la transition énergétique ne peut
se raésonner à titre individuel État par
État ça ne peut être qu'une approche je
dirais d'ensemble donc moi j'appelle de
mes vœux déjà depuis quelques temps une
coopération renforcée en la
matière je j'ai salué avec intérêt la
création du groupe magrid par Monsieur
Mestral GDF su ma question est donc la
suivante comment un grand groupe tel que
tel que le vôre
peut-il pertinemment intéresser les
pouvoirs publics pour essayer de faire
comprendre que la la création d'une
Europe de l'énergie est aujourd'hui une
urgente nécessité vous allez me dire
c'est une décision politique
euh uniquement politique certes je je je
le conçois sauf que s'il y a des
pressions d'un certain nombre de grandes
entreprises la décision elle sera plus
elle sera prise plus aisément et plus
rapidement et pour moi à mon avis si on
veut réindustrialiser l'Europe si on
veut réindustri réindustrialiser la
France l'urgence de la création d'une
Europe de l'énergie est plus que jamais
d'actualité merci monsieur le Président
la parole est à la défense merci
monsieur le Président je me sens pas
tellement agressé d'ailleurs dans les
propos mais euh je vais essayer de
répondre S et puis si j'oublie tel ou
tel sujet je vous prie de m'en excuser
je je suis tout à fait disposé à revenir
en arrière ou en tout cas compléter bon
d'abord je
voudrais revenir sur les fondamentaux
c'estàd on fond EDF n'est pas un
producteur d'énergie électrique euh EDF
est un opérateur de service public c'est
un peu différ si je peux me
permettre c'est assez différent pourquoi
parce que nous avons une mission de
service public cette mission de service
public elle consiste à donner au
territoire national et à ses concitoyens
à la fois l'énergie en quantité en durée
en pérénité de service en compétitivité
suffisante pour assurer cette mission
ceci étant posé ça veut dire que DF
n'est en rien hostile aux économies
d'énergie alors on regarde parfois de
manière un peu étonnée mais com
qu'est-ce que vous allez faire pourquoi
est-ce que vous vous battez pour faire
des économies d'énergie alors que vous
êtes vendeur d'électricité et
deuxièmement EDF n'est pas le lobby
nucléaire quand on regarde F
globalement dans le monde entier en
dehors de la France et la
Grande-Bretagne ailleurs on n pas
nucléaire donc on est on est en fonction
des pays plus ou moins orientés vers
l'optimisation
et
l'existant donc on s'adapte il vrait par
là repousser un pe l'idée que on défend
nucléaire parce qu'au fond c'est notre
spécialité notre notre expertise non non
on a plusieurs expertises on est les
premiers développeurs d'énergie nouvelle
en Europe effectivement nous sommes les
premiers opérateurs nucléaires au monde
encore une fois les premiers
hydroliciens alors en Europe au monde
non puisque les ressources hydrauliques
du du Canada de la Russie du
Brésil sont telles que effectivement on
n'est pas compé enfin on est en volume
et et la Chine maintenant avec les Trois
Gorges font que aujourd'hui on est le
5ème opérateur mondial derrière c'est
mamouth mais c'est mamouth qui sont là
parce que les raisons géographiques et
géologiques sont telles qu'on peut pas
être compétitif sauf si et c'est ce à
quoi on travaille on se développe
partout dans le monde dans l'hydraulique
de manière à en fait on peut pas se
limiter à la France de toute façon le DF
est trop gros aujourd'hui pour être
exclusivement français nous avons une
mission de service public en France don
nous avons la fierté de l'assumer de
l'assumer de manière efficace et de
répondre à toutes les questions et et
c'est questions de la transition
énergétique en France c'est une question
qui se pose à nous auquel on essaie de
donner les meilleur P possible mais sans
qu'il y ait un sous-jacent je dirais d'à
priori industriel bon non on essaie de
faire en sorte que la mission de service
public soit soit soit soit je dirais le
mode d'ordre et et le fil conducteur de
notre démarche m'envis pas si je le
rappelle mais c'est important je crois
de de de de
systématiquement le remettre en point
d'or parce que sinon on apparaîtra comme
étant toujours de partie prix c'est pas
le sujet bon si j'avais le sentiment
qu'au fond il faait véritablement
baisser la puissance nucléaire de la
France parce que c'est l'intérêt de la
France je le ferai spontanément sans
qu'on me le demande donc donc n'y voyez
pas le moindre coûte dans le
raisonnement deuxièmement la loi Nome
bon alors en France la les politiques
françaises les gouvernements successifs
ont décidé à la fois d'assurer
l'indépendance énergétique la
prévisibilité et la compétitivité du
territoire qui ont été à l'origine de
l'aventure nucléaire française qui a été
confié à EDF qui a rendu sa copie
aujourd'hui on peut le reconnaître avec
un certain succès mais par ailleurs
comme les pouvoirs publics ont décidé de
ne pas casser l'outil nucléaire pour ne
pour font préserver à la fois la Sûreté
Nucléaire d'une part la compétitivité la
compétence de l'autre et éviter le
désordre qu'aurait provoqué la sission
en plusieurs morceaux du parc nucléaire
et bien du fait de la compétitivité de
ce parc nucléaire on nous a forcé à
accepter une loi qui nous qui nous fasse
subventionner la concurrence c'estàd
qu'au fond la loi de nom qu'est-ce que
c'est on vend notre capacité
électronucléaire 25 % de la production
électronucléaire française à nos
concurrents à un prix significativement
inférieur à son coup de revient je vous
ai dit que son coup de revient était à
55 € je le maintiens nous l'avions dit à
l'époque certains de nos concurrents
prétendaient que c'était 31 € bullshit
total enfin aujourd'hui on le sait qu'il
mtait bon on ne tire pas les
conséquences nécessaires ils ont menti
je dis simplement que on a accepté 42 €
parce que c'était le niveau du TaRTAM à
l'époque passant enfin bon personne ne
connaît la famille l'oncle le papa la
maman tartame enfin bon c'était 42 € le
tartame d'été voyez ENF il y avait une
tartame d'été un tartame d'hiver et
cetera enfin fallait hyper spécialiste
pardon Jean-Claude mais ça existait on a
dit bon allez 42 bon je me suis batttu
comme un chien pour avoir 42 € on a eu
42 € qui était bien sûr inférieur au cû
au coup économi donc on peut pas nous
reprocher aujourd'hui que le coût
économique soit supérieur simplement
répondre à la question est-ce que le
prix a dérivé non c'était déjà 55
ce sont eux qui l'ont voté je vous oui
oui non mais euh je voudrais simplement
soulager les scrupules Morau de Monsieur
sido on n pas dérapé c'est simplement
que c'était déjà le
cas
pardon ah oui non mais c'est stupide non
c'est pas le prix le 42 c'était une
convention c'était un prix prix de
cession favorable c'està direire qu'on
subventionnerit la concurrence pour
qu'elle puisse venir nous piquer des
parts de marché c'est assz original mais
on est les seuls industriels au monde à
qui ont uneous demande de financer les
concurrents pour qu'ils viennent vous
piquer des parts de marché vous êtes
éligible auss hier donc euh donc c'est
bien quoi mais euh dans la mission de
service public il y a aussi le fait de
subventionner les concurrents c'est
comme
ça donc oui au service énergétique oui à
l'optimisation énergétique sous quelle
forme alors c'est vrai que la maison EDF
n'y était pas nécessairement
préalablement accoutumé parce que
c'était pas son métier d'origine
d'autant plus que jusqu'en 2006 date
d'ouverture du marché EDF avait
l'interdiction l'interdiction par le
principe de spécialité de développer des
services énergétiques d'où l'initiative
qui avait été prise par Moné
prédécesseur François rousli avec ma
petite personne à l'origine de l'accord
d'Alia qui présidait au destin de cette
entreprise de Veolia lorsque nous avons
croisé nos destins avec EDF pour créer
cette plateforme de service énergétique
commune entre dal Olia que nous allons
récupérer aujourd'hui qui était qui
avait vocation à être le complément
d'objet direct de service énergétique
donc d'optimisation énergétique à
l'opérateur historique aujourd'hui on va
le récupérer et on va avoir une offre de
service à la fois dans l'optimisation
énergétique pour le logement le bâtiment
et l'entreprise au travers de dalka et
les collectivités territoriales réseau
de chauffage de froid et cetera en même
temps pour l'industrie service
industriel optimisation de système
d'énergie pour les entreprises en même
temps que l'éclairage public qui tallume
en même temps que les services
énergétiques répartis à la maille locale
avec notamment le waste to énergie euh
avec
euh avec TIRU et cetera donc vous voyez
on a un bloc de service et
d'optimisation énergétique qui va être
demain à partir du mois de juillet euh
le complément d'objet direct de de du du
réacteur euh EDF sur euh sur la maille
locale d'une part l'optimisation
énergétique d'autre part je rajoute à ça
que dans les débats que nous avons eu en
France sur les sujets énergétiques quand
euh le sujet s'est posé de la fameuse
discussion sur la loi de Nome en
2000 et ce combat homérique pour obtenir
les 42 € qui évidemment comme je te
rappelais à l'instant je vais pas me
répéter à l'époque 2012 pardon sorait
une réglementation
thermique pourquoi pas si n'est qu'on
l'a confié à gaz-defance qui a rédigé le
texte de l'optimisation la
réglementation thermique comme par
hasard la réglementation thermique
française est totalement pro gazière
c'està-dire au fond aujourd'hui alors on
peut pas se battre sur tous les fronts
je m'étais battu sur le front de la
loiom je pouvais pas en même temps pour
éviter de me faire curiasser me battre
sur le problème de la réation
qu'aujourd'hui je pose la question elle
est très ouverte pourquoi est-ce que
cette réglementation thermique est
autant en faveur du gaz c'està-dire de
l'énergie importée et pourquoi est-ce
qu'elle ne répond pas aux attente de
l'optimisation en matière de logement la
question est ouverte monsieurs msieurs
les parlementaires et donc au fond moi
je me dis qu'une réglementation peut
être suivie d'une autre réglementation
qu'elle est pas figée dans le marbre et
qu'on peut toujours réfléchir j'incite à
la réflexion car j'ai le souci
aujourd'hui de dans l'optimisation du
système énergétique français au sens
large que les économies d'énergie
l'optimisation énergétique du logement
ne passe pas forcément par les
importations gazières et que cette
réglementation mérite d'être au moins
réactualisée c'est tout ce que je veux
dire pardon mais je me devais de de le
rappeler parce que dès lors qu'on parle
d'économie d'énergie d'optimisation
énergétique il faut voir toute la
palette des mesures alors les mesures
incitatives font partie de cette
démarche bien donc oui EDF sera un
acteur et un acteur important de
l'optimisation énergétique économie
d'énergie parce que c'est son c'est sa
mission et j'allais dire c'est son
métier et nous le ferons complètement ce
qui ne veut pas dire pour autant que en
complément d'objet direct
nous repartions sur comment est-ce qu'on
peut optimiser le système énergétique
qui qui nous est euh qui nous est
comment dirais-je confié c'est-à-dire
l'électricité et que bah une partie de
l'optimisation viendra du mix
énergétique àonde de fabrication une
autre partie viendra en aval de des
économies d'énergie la troisième partie
viendra au milieu des réseaux
intelligents qui font partie du système
électrique et donc euh les les smart
grid et donc les les réseaux
intelligents qui seront un des éléments
clés de l'optimisation énergétique et
nous nous investissons simultanément sur
la mon sur laav et sur les
réseaux je confère les 6 milliards que
nous allons investir pour le compteur
dit interactif qui sera un des premiers
éléments des réseaux intelligents pas le
seul et de l'autre et puis tout ça parce
qu'on est un grand opérateur
mondial drainene toute une industrie
sousjacente oui nous sommes les leaders
parce qu'on on est l'opérateur de
référence en matière nucléaire et qu'il
est légitime normal que nous assumions
une responsabilité particulière dans la
filière industrielle du nucléaire
français dans le monde oui et nous le
faisons de façon
délibérée volontaire et
responsable parce que c'est quand je
l'ai dit à une certaine
époque semble mêtre fait critiquer il
c'est 250000 emplois direct la filière
industrielle nucléire français c'est la
troisème filière industrielle française
derrière l'automobile et
l'aéronautique ne l'oublions pas ces
emplois si on gagne la la bataille du
nucléaire mondial il ne demande qu'à se
développer c'est notre responsabilité
collective et en tout cas c'est la
mienne
ensuite vous avez toute la démarche
industrielle dans les autres systèmes
électriques dans les autres moyens de
production vous avez parlé des énergies
nouvelles nous sommes le premier
développeur d'énergie nouvelle au monde
en Europe travers desdf énergie nouvelle
don nous maîtrisons désormais 100 % du
capital et bien nous développons ces
énergies nouvelles partout où c'est
rationnel parce que la mission de
service public fait que plutôt que de
rebondir sur les modes ou sur les
spéculations au moment en 2011 2010
début 2010 où je
visite la campagne française d'And
dévastée par la tempête caerina je vois
le président du conseil général et je lu
dis Président je trouve que nous
connaissons tous bientôt votre
département sera une immense ferme
photovoltaïque il y aura plus
d'habitants parce qu'il y aura plus
d'espace bon simplement les 600 € le
mgawh de subvention versé enfin de tarif
garanti pour le le photovoltaïque dans
les Landes était tellement élevé 600 €
MW que tous les propriétaires terriens
avaient intérêt à fabriquer des fermes
photovoltaïques plutôt qu'à faire
repousser des pains par que le le le le
le le revenu annuel procuré par les
fermes photovoltaïques était deux fois
supérieur à la valeur de leur patrimoine
chaque année bon il y a eu une
spéculation folle quand on voit le
désastre allemand c'est la conséquence
de d'une spéculation financière c'est ni
plus ni moins que ça quand je rencontre
le ministre allemand de l'énergie il y a
maintenant un peu plus de 12 mois qui
était à l'époque ministre allemand de
l'énergie il est
maintenant ministre à la Chancellerie
monsur altmer il dit gu vous savez je
vous faire une confidence le montant des
subventions déjà accordé renouvela
allemand dépasse les 1200 milliards
d'euros
bon capitalisé sur les 20 ans de contrat
puisque c'est ce sont des contrats
plannuels comme chez nous ça veut dire
que c'était 20 % de plus que la
réunification allemande on s'étonne
après du
désastre donc c'est vrai que l'Allemagne
est un contreexemple aujourd'hui on peut
le dire les Allemands eux-mêm le
reconnaissent alors qu'il y a un an
simplement il était malsin de le dire
parce que c'était pas politiquement
correct de fait on est devant ce
désastre là ce qui fait que les deux
opér allemand sont aujourd'hui un un
état avancé de décomposition voire de
dépôt de bilan pour l' l'un des
deux constatz quand je vends notre
filiale allemande en
2011 bon je la vend pour 7 milliards
d'euros elle ne vaut plus
rien bon
elle ne vaut plus
donc parce que il était évident que ça
allait tourner au désastre c'était bien
c'était é avant les événements donc bon
donc donc voilà la réalité donc donc la
mission de service public fait que DF ne
peut pas se permettre d'être spéculateur
financier ne peut pas se permettre de ne
pas de ne pas anticiper ne peut pas se
permettre d'être simplement dépouser les
contours des modes mais se sent
responsable sur la durée de cette
mission et de sa responsabilité
vis-à-vis de la France et des Français
et de l'économie française une des
questions c'est est-ce que nous
acceptons oui on acceptera de toute
façon d'accompagner l'économie française
et l'industrie française dans la limite
du raisonnable c'est-à-dire il ne s'agit
pas d'aller subventionner entre
guillemets des entreprises en difficulté
c'est pas le sujet mais s'il s'agit de
donner à l'entreprise France aux
entreprises installées en France quel
que soit leur nationalité un atout
compétitif qui s'appelle l'lectricité
oui on le fera dès lors que c'est
possible dès lors qu'on aura les
autorisations dès lors qu'on sera pas
condamneré à Bruxelles pour êre d'État
donc il faut être assez attentif aux
modalités opératoires on on a signé des
contrats dans cette perspective là on
les a avenanté de manière et cetera je
ne veux pas trop mal m'apesantir sur ces
sujets parce qu'il nous rendent
vulnérabl aux attaques de nos chers
concurrents l'Europe de l'énergie
n'existe pas on parle pas d'une page
blanche aujourd'hui la compétition
fitrage entre les pays européens on a on
a nous avons collectivement la France a
un atout dans ce
domaine alors la solidarité c'est pas
forcément de partager l'atou avec ceux
qui n'en ont pas parce que finalement on
n'est pas assez riche pour ça donc
l'égoïsme c'est-à-dire la compétitivité
du territoire parce que si on doit faire
la différence on la fera sur nos atouts
et pas sur nos faiblesses soyons
conscients de nos faiblesses essayons de
les contourner mais soyons conscients
aussi de nos atout essayons de ne pas
les partager c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
tout le monde nous jalouse notre
compétitivité dans le domaine électrique
les attaques dont nous sommes
systématiques par l'objet c'est pas une
raison pour les pour les partager donc
je pense que avant de passer de l'Europe
de de parler de l'Europe de l'énergie
parlons de la France de l'énergie et
parlons des atouts français et puis
ensuite parlons des défauts des autres
et puis voyons comment éventuellement
nos atouts peuvent leur permettre à eux
d'avoir je dirais une réponse à leurs
question mais sans pour autant négliger
notre compétitivité ni notre nos
quelques avantages encore une fois qui
sont très importants pour l'emploi pour
la compétitivité du territoire et pour
l'entreprise
France sur
euh
sur le coût de l'énergie encore une fois
nous n'avons aucune aucun atout dans les
autres énergies que dans l'électricité
puis que les autres énergie par
définition sont orté enfin les énergies
fossiles en tout cas les
énergies nouvelles entre guillemets
renouvelables l'hydraolique bien entendu
qui est la première d'entrée et les
autres énergies renouvelables doivent
être sollicité pour autant qu'elles sont
rationnelles c'estàdire qu'elles
obéissent c'est vrai qu'il vaut mieux
faire du photovoltaïque la du soleil
malheureusement on a eu l'habitude pour
compenser des gens qui n'avait pas la
chance d'avoir du soleil de leur donner
des prix des subventions plus
importantes que là où il y a du soleil
ce qui fait que on a beaucoup développé
le photovotaïque dans le Nord et
beaucoup moins dans le sud pas forcément
rationnel mais ça faisait partie de
voilà des revendications naturellement
des territoires c'est normal que
quelqu'un qui n'a pas de soleil veuille
se compenser son manque de soleil par
des subventions mais le problème c'est
que ça marche pas dans l'énergie et
c'est comme ça que l'Allemagne a
développé beaucoup de photovoltaïque au
nord de l'Allemagne alors c'est assez
original parce que quand on connaît le
nord de l'Allemagne on sait qu'il est
pas écrasé de soleil enfin pas tous les
jours en tout Cason et de la même
manière on a fait du photo du du de
l'éolien là où il y avait pas de vent
mais mais bientôt et pour des raisons
écolo d'ailleurs on nous fera faire des
éoliennes dans les talveg protéger du
vent parce qu'ils seront en profondeur
mais c'est vrai que c'est pas totalement
rationnel il vaut mieux le mettre sur
des crêtes
que que que dans des bas bon mais mais
là aussi la subvention fausse tout s
suffit de contrebalancer par des
subventions des conditions économiques
ou des conditions géographiques
défavorables alors c'est vrai que ça
conduit à des conclusions un peu
absurdes voilà ce que je voulais dire en
quelque sorte
euh les collectivités territoriales ont
un rôle absolument déterminant à jouer
dès lors
que on on on on regarde le problème 1
des économies d'énergie et de
l'optimisation énergétique parce que
c'est vrai que par exemple dans le dans
le logement qui mieux que les élus
locaux connaissent le patrimoine et euh
et connaissent les les l'efficacité des
interventions qui peuvent être réalisées
donc au fond
d centralisé rapproché de du territoire
tous les efforts d'optimisation
énergétique me paraît vraisemblablement
la meilleure solution sans pour
autant faire en sorte que il y ait des
connexions entre la maille territoriale
et la maille nationale parce qu'il faut
que ça soit cohérent il faut que le
système soit cohérent c'est-à-dire que
le système réparti et le système
centralisé travaille la main dans la
main de manière efficace et que chacun
sache qui fait quoi de manière à ce
qu'il ni redondance ni rupture de
raésonnement je crois beaucoup au
système intégré je crois beaucoup à
l'efficacité du système intégré je crois
au fait que les réseaux s'intteg
parfaitement à l'amont et à l'aval du
cycle parce que dès lors qu'on sépare
les réseaux de la production et de la
commercialisation et de l'optimisation
énergétique on va vers des incohérences
on le voit dans le faire de manière un
peu caricaturale on peut le faire aussi
dans l'électricité c'est assez facile de
répliquer ou de dupliquer des bêtises
mais lorsquon se rend compte qu'on les a
faites c'est pas la peine d'essayer de
d'en ajouter une à une autre pour pour
pour démontrer qu'on est capable de le
faire c'est déjà c'est déjà assez
clair